make a long story short
I almost lost my wife
my 67 Corvette hey guys I'm off the grid
for August but the elderly man
pretending to be president takes no time
off slurring everything
I don't want to
compare difficulties but we have a
little sense Jill and I
what it's like to lose a home
years ago now 15 years ago I was in
Washington doing Meet the Press
it was a sunny Sunday
and lightning struck at home
on a little Lake it's outside of our
home not a like a big pond
and hit a wire and came up underneath
our home
into the heating Ducks the air
conditioning duct make a long story
short
almost lost my wife
my 67 Corvette
and my cat
walking inside
I watched the firefighters
the way they responded
no there's no expression
I grew up right across the street from a
fire hall in Claymont Delaware
foreign